viewers have found a lot to like about
the Netflix original series The Witcher
which stars erstwhile Superman Henry
Cavill as Geralt of Rivia the
protagonist of the well-loved series of
video games it's well-written briskly
paced lovingly rendered fantasy fun and
while some critics have tried to rain on
fans parade those fans have been quick
to write off these half-baked criticisms
rightly so in our humble opinion a good
number appear to have been fielded by
critics who either don't care for the
fantasy genre in general or can't keep
from comparing The Witcher to the
recently ended Game of Thrones which is
frankly a ridiculously weak comparison
cavil acquits himself nicely in the lead
but viewers have been particularly taken
with the character of yennefer a
sorceress with a troubled history and
decidedly mixed feelings about Geralt
tell me other women you find this
closeness charming maybe somebody's
where they find you a coin for a
champion date the show-stealing
magic-user who becomes ever more
powerful as the first season goes on and
eventually has occasion to use her
formidable powers to take on an entire
army single-handedly is portrayed by a
young actress in yo chill ultra a
relative newcomer whom you might
nevertheless find to be a bit familiar
if you can't quite put your finger on
where you've seen her before well we're
here to help
Shailaja hasn't been in the business for
very long but her talent has already
earned her some pretty high-profile gigs
since we'll assume you're a fan of The
Witcher you obviously have a Netflix
subscription meaning that you might have
caught her debut credit 2018 s
wanderlust a drama series which is a
joint production between the streamer
and BBC one the series stars Toni
Collette as joy Richards a therapist
whose life goes into a downward spiral
after both the death of one of her
patients and a terrible car accident in
which she's badly injured the series is
the brainchild of British playwright
Nick Payne who recently branched out
into feature film work with his
screenplay for the 2017 adaptation of
Julianne Barnes's novel the sense of an
ending it's well received first season
introduced chill autre in a minor role
and gave her the opportunity to work
alongside the always excellent Colette
as well as co-stars steven mackintosh
and Zooey Ashton while the series first
season left a number of narrative
threads dangling there hasn't yet been
any word on whether a second has
received the
official greenlight let alone weather
chill autre will return whether or not
the young stars tapped for another round
of wanderlust though it appears likely
she'll be kept plenty busy also in 2018
Shallotte reappeared in the BBC One
miniseries the ABC murders and
adaptation of the classic Agatha
Christie novel of the same name once
again she had the privilege of working
with an outstanding cast led by the
great John Malkovich as Hercule Poirot
the miniseries is available for
streaming in the US on Amazon Prime
video interestingly chill autre has also
shown an early talent for voice acting
the only other credit on her resume the
YouTube premium animated series Sherwood
an ambitious futuristic adaptation of
the Robin Hood legend set in the 23rd
century Shallotte relieves the series as
the gender swapped Robin Loxley her
co-stars include tyler posey jamie chung
rachel house and joseph fiennes
she may be a relatively new face but
with credits this interesting chalo
Chara has already proven her versatility
and with the witcher she's proven that
she can win over fans and hold her own
against the charismatic likes of cavil
what here we go to summon chaos on
King's orders in between feeding and
naps do not patronize me we think it's
safe to say that we'll be seen much much
more of her in the years to come
while her IMDB page doesn't currently
list any upcoming projects we already
know that we'll be getting a second
season of The Witcher as it was renewed
by Netflix before the first season even
dropped given fans warm response to the
character of universe of Coal ultra
weren't given an expanded role for the
series second outing check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about The Witcher are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]